What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series
Where YOU
Challenge US
With your craziest ideas
Related to table tennis
If your idea gets picked
We will feature it
And give you a shout out
So make sure you leave your ideas
In the comment-section below!
This idea comes from Dry Ice Thug
We will spin around this stick
And try to make around the net shots
This is going to be horrible!
I know...
That's way too difficult!
Henil Patel wants us to play a topspin rally
When only using our backhands.
Let's do it.
I don't feel good about this!
WOOOOW!!
C'mon!
That went well!
Emanuel Koscak wants us to play with a coffee
pot
Me and Otto both brought our favorite pots
with us
RandomDestroyerYT wants us to hit a ping pong
ball
Through the windows of a moving car
Let's do it!
Thank you!
Not good.
Thanks for watching guys!
If you enjoyed this episode
Make sure to leave it a thumbs up!
And if you want to support our channel even
more
Remember to get your own Pongfinity
Hoodies and T-shirts
From the link below.
Also, subscribe right here
And watch our previous episodes here.
Until next time!